[Music]
Hey everybody, thanks for coming to my
talk. Uh, I am Nathan Sobo. I'm the
co-founder of Zed. We are an AI enabled
code editor. And what sets us apart is
we are not a fork of VS Code. We are
implemented from scratch.
[Applause]
uh implemented from scratch in Rust. We
literally engineered the entire system
like a video game around about 1,200
lines of shader program that run on the
GPU and the rest of the system is
organized to deliver frames at 120
frames per second really quickly. And
recently I recorded a video because time
is short and I this is obviously sped up
massively but we launched Agentic
Editing in Zed and I wanted to talk
about the approach that we took to test
this uh and be empirical and deliver a
reliable product that does this
effectively. So here's what we're going
to be talking about. The rest of the
talk is going to be looking at code and
just talking about our experience. Um so
testing evaluation what's the
difference? Um first I just want to
start by saying like without an
empirical approach to the software that
we've been building since 2018 2021
depends on how long you measure it zed
would crash every 8 seconds like uh we
have probably tens of thousands of tests
at this point. And here's an example of
the extreme to which we take empirical
software development. We literally are
starting a server, creating two clients,
and we have a simulated scheduler that
gets passed in here and we run 50
different iterations of this with every
random interle of anything that could
possibly be concurrent. Um, so that if
the 375th, thousandth, and this is only
50, but uh iteration of this particular
interle of network packets um goes
wrong, we can replay that over and over
again, freeze it, and have full control.
So we're very hardcore about testing and
being empirical at Zed. But up until
very recently until shipping some of
these AI related features, we've been
able to be fully deterministic. Even
with sort of non-deterministic things,
we've been able to really lock things
down and never have flaky tests on CI.
But as soon as an LLM enters the
picture, that's all out the window,
right? because we could like you know
assuming that we're using you know uh
frontier models but even if we were to
use our own model and to like control
the sampling off the lojits you change
one token in the input and you're going
to get a completely different output. So
it's just a fundamentally different
problem where we have to embrace
stochastic behavior. And so as we built
this system, our first eval that we
really hammered on was something that if
you've seen something like SWE probably
looks pretty familiar. It's very
datadriven. And it seems like in the
machine learning world like this is what
an AVAL is. Input output. But in the
programmatic software world, an eval is
more like a test that passes or fails.
like we come from this very different
perspective of automated testing and so
right away you know we had this
traditional datadriven eval and then
backing that you know in the same
program we al uh that runs all these
eval basically compiles a headless copy
of zed checks out a repo runs the agent
tries to make it do things um we right
away got into like making the eval more
programmatic you can see here the
conversation is literally a function and
then our ability to sort of come in here
and write code that performs assertions
about what the agent did. Even, you
know, getting a quite a bit more
granular because the problem is when
that big aval fails, it's like what do
we do? There's a million ways that that
thing could go wrong. And so when we
wrote this eval, we were able to drive
out uh one really simple failure mode,
which is when we run the GP tool, this
is what our original like dumb
implementation of the GP tool looked
like. So you can see in this case we're
saying we want to add uh a window
argument to this tool run trait method
in this particular file name right but
if this is what the model sees then
we're in trouble right and so what we
ended up you know driving from this
stochastic test here is a more
deterministic test right where I'm going
to go ahead and set up the project uh
perform this search for fn run and Then
uh we use tree sitter which is um Max's
parsing uh parser generator framework to
actually expand out the match to the
syntactic boundaries. Um and so that was
able to you know drive a a substantial
improvement in the behavior of the
agent. So right there like that was an
interesting discovery of just being
empirical and driving out what was
ultimately an algorithmic problem with a
stochastic test. But then we moved on to
the editing. And when we first
implemented editing, it was just done
with tool calls. But the problem with
tool calls, if anybody's worked with
them, is they don't really stream very
well. Like you get p value key P key P
key P key P key P key P key P key P key
P key P key P key P key P key P key P
key P key P key P key P key P value and
it all comes back at once. So we what we
ended up doing is deciding instead we
perform a small tool call that just
describes the edits. Then we loop back
around for the moment to just the same
model because it has everything already
loaded in its cache and ask it to emit
these old text new text blocks. Um, but
there's some challenges there like now
we have to parse that data is coming
back and all kinds of weird stuff that
the model's going to be doing. So I'll
just dive in and show you um some of the
examples. So here's like
uh there were a bunch of different uh
tests like these are part of our main
regular old test suite and we just added
this eval function and we say I want to
run this eval 200 times and in this
particular case didn't start this way
but eventually we got this way we want
100% of these 200 examples to pass or
this test should like literally fail the
build. So we kind of set a watermark
that way. And then here you can see I'm
just like loading in a conversation with
the LLM. Um and then ultimately uh in
this case I'm using uh eval as judge but
there are some cases you saw earlier
where we do things more
programmatically. This case we're just
like verifying that this thing worked
correctly. Um and so we go from a test
like this a stochastic test into the
particular problems um that drive this.
So I mean but it's funny a lot of the
things that went wrong here were really
just like basic things right like and so
again these are things that we can
they're non-deterministic but the
non-determinism is non-determinism
is sort of bounded. So in this case,
we're going to run a 100 iterations of
this very simple parsing test where
we're randomly
chunking up the input into arbitrary
boundaries and just making sure that the
parser for this data u you know can
handle arbitrary chunking of of the
text. Similarly here fuzzy matching
algorithm that's a critical piece of you
know if the model's fuzzy or generates
something slightly wrong. Being able to
do this dynamic programming that gets us
an approximate match really saved a lot
of the tool calling failures for us. But
again something that could be
deterministically tested. And then
finally, there's this idea of a
streaming diff that as the model is
emitting new text, we need to be care
comparing the new text it's emitting
with the old text and then making a
dynamic decision of if I don't see some
text is that in that was present in the
old text, is that because it was deleted
or it just hasn't been streamed out yet?
So that's another, you know, completely
uh deterministic thing that still was
critical to making the system work
correctly. So yet another like
deterministic test. Um but then we get
into some of the fun stuff with uh uh
the behavior of the model itself. So one
thing that we noticed right away was um
the model when it was trying to insert
at the top or the end of the document in
some cases would just have an empty old
text tag which like if you're doing old
text new text matching is not very
useful. And so we found that we were
able to just add this you know simple
thing to the prompt and improve the eval
but again it would still do it you know
one or two% of the time and so just
being able to test that uh you know we
can handle that case robustly um you
know ended up being really helpful and
this is just like again I'm in this case
simulating the output of the LLM. Um,
uh, another case that we encountered a
lot was that it would mismatch the XML
tags. And so we would have old text and
then it would end like this with new
text. Um, and so again, we were able to
get a certain distance with the prompt.
We initially were sort of 40% of the
time we were getting this mismatch and
blowing up. We were able to move that by
saying always close all tags properly to
like 95%.
But we still have that last like 5%.
What do we do with that? And so again,
it's just like
driving it into a deterministic test
where we have old text, new text, you
know, and we need to just assert that
even though we got, you know, we just
need to be robust and accept crazy stuff
from the LLM like uh in its output. Um,
another interesting case was
indentation. So here's a naval that uh
that we wrote which was this idea of
having an outer function and then inside
here there's an inner function and we
have this to-do macro here and we want
to say replace this to-do with return 42
and we would see the model doing things
like this right where the indentation
level was completely
flattened out right it says replace fn
inner but fn inner has like all this
leading indentation on the front of it
um but otherwise like it's perfectly
fine
And so in this case what we did is this
strategy of like detecting this indent
delta. So we figure out basically
we sort of renormalize the indent if
that makes sense. So if the text in the
buffer is indented by a certain amount
but we otherwise match then we also
detect the text in the that the LLM
emitted and compute this delta. And then
again driving it back to a deterministic
test of um here we build a buffer with
Lauram ipsum doler sit with this very
interesting indentation pattern and then
you can see here we want to replace
ipsom dollar sit with ipsom dollar derit
a met where it's outded right and you
can see that when we actually do our uh
indentation normalization we're able to
handle that correctly Um, another tricky
thing that we ran into was this weird
escaping behavior where in these certain
cases where we have weird constructs
like this is a Rust um sort of a raw
string basically that can include uh
things like quotes inside of it due to
this interesting escaping syntax and
doing something as simple as saying just
like tweak this. We would notice this is
the behavior we want. we would notice
especially Gemini doing all kinds of
crazy stuff like doing HTML escape codes
um doing this sort of backslashes
escaping
yeah with new lines and stuff we would
see like you know uh crazy escaping that
it would do uh double escaping the new
lines um and so in this case like we
that was just a pure prompt fix and
didn't really we didn't try yet at least
to kind of detect any of this escaping
any further although obviously like
that's an opportunity yeah to keep going
even further. Um so yeah I mean from
from my perspective like the lessons we
learned from this entire experience is
that like
rigorous testing is fundamental to
building reliable software period. uh we
have this new fancy parlance of like an
eval which comes I think out of the
machine learning field of kind of input
output and having lots of examples of
that but I think a lot of the techniques
of just traditional good old-fashioned
software engineering are still really
applicable but we have to embrace this
more statistical approach where we're
running it 100 times 200 times and
asserting a threshold of pass versus
fail um but I think I mean this is a
real world example of just the stuff
that we saw trying to implement
streaming edits or an agent that can go
search and edit. A lot of those problems
are not I don't know they're not
advanced machine learning problems or
anything. It's just stupid things that
the model will try to do that we need to
account for. Um, and so this I I think
this motion of sort of starting with the
zoomed out eval then zooming into a sort
of stochastic unit test that's still
random and interacting with the model
but is more focused in on a particular
aspect of the experience and then
finally that driving that even further
to an actual good oldfashioned test.
That's been the process that we've
discovered, but we so far haven't needed
to use like special external tools um or
eval frameworks or anything of like
that. It's just in our test suite so far
and kind of using the same underlying
infrastructure that's used to do any
other kind of software testing and
honestly using just a lot of those same
skills. Um, so for us it was like just
be empirical just like we've always
been, but it's this new X factor of the
LLM doing all these crazy things. Um,
yeah. So that's that's a little story of
how we and this is all open source, so
you can check it out. Uh, Zed is under
the GPL license. I'd love help improving
it all actually. Um, maybe some of you
are like, what are you doing? You could
do better in the following five ways.
I'd love uh contributions if that's
interesting to folks. And um yeah, it's
working. I'm uh with the Claude 4
models, I'm finally able to write Rust
agentically really efficiently and I'm
just loving it. So um that's how we got
there. I appreciate your attention.
[Music]